près de la frontière entre l'ukraine et
la russie un nouvel exercice militaire a
démarré marty quelques 3000 soldats
russes se sont remis en mouvement dans
le sud-ouest de leur pays un message du
kremlin pour manifester sa déception à
l'issue des premières négociations entre
la russie et les etats unis les
américains eux sont chargés d'apaiser
les tensions et d'éviter une éventuelle
invasion russe du territoire ukrainien
cent mille soldats russes sont toujours
massés à la frontière alors même que
deux nouvelles rencontres sont prévues
pour de nouveaux pourparlers
à six ces pourparlers se poursuivent ça
mais ils ne seront couronnés de succès
que si nous pouvons les mener dans une
atmosphère de désescalade
l'ukraine ne devrait pas voir cette épée
de damoclès au dessus d'elle côté russe
alors que les soldats sont présents aux
abords de la frontière depuis plusieurs
semaines l'état continue de nier une
volonté d' invasion la région est
ukrainienne du don bas se déchire déjà
entre séparatistes pro russes et forces
gouvernementales ukrainienne depuis plus
de sept ans pour la nation de vladimir
poutine un point reste incontournable
sur ce dossier l'ukraine ne doit en
aucun cas rejoindre l'alliance militaire
transatlantique l'otan le kremlin
considéré alors le pays comme une base
avancée des états unis aux portes de la
russie en cas de conflit
pendant longtemps nous avons assuré une
partie de la sécurité de l'europe mais
le temps a commencé à s'étendre à l'est
de manière agressive une expansion
dangereuse qu'elle était accompagnée de
plusieurs actions offensives
ce mercredi plusieurs hauts responsables
de l'otan doivent rencontrer les
représentants russes pour tenter
d'amorcer une désescalade